give up  i've been making these videos for a  while now i've got over a thousand  videos and i've realized from all the  people who write in and you know what  it's just too hard to be an entrepreneur  being an entrepreneur sucks and the  stats are not with you you know 80  percent of companies are going to fail  that's going to be you so why risk  your money your time your pride your  dignity doing something is just going to  fail just stop  quit do the safe thing get a job you  know the people in your life were  telling you to stay the safe route  they're right listen to the little man  the little man isn't the little man the  little man is the voice of reason  all the time you put into this business  it's not worth it it's not going to work  out you should just quit that's it  i've had enough  i'm just joking come on april fool's day  you know i believe when you guys you can  make it don't listen to the little man  stomp him out keep believing in your  company believe guys